let's bring you some pictures now that
we believe this is the moment of the
battle at was stormed we can see there
what we believe is police climbing a
ladder whether this was actually just
after those explosions were heard but
the sequence of events appears to be
that the police moved in very quickly
after they heard these explosions but it
appears too late because the reports are
at least a hundred people have died in
that theater
two gunmen one at least with explosives
being reported and well there we are we
can hear some of maybe the stun grenades
that were used by the police as the
material and then heavy gunfire the
police operation announced earlier by
France advancing the assault had been
planned
now whether in fact by that stage those
hostages inside the theater had been
killed we don't know but clearly
something indicated to the police that
they had to move in very quickly
[Music]
Alistair that appeared to be a stun
grenade with a big white flash that you
get noise and and the light at the same
time yeah I think so
probably the G IGN as well which is the
counter terror unit from the French
gendarme going in either that or the
head which is the RAI D who are the
counter terror equivalent from the
French National Police absolutely superb
I mean world-class they proved that in
the shoddy until attacks they've proved
it on a number of occasions and as we've
said before I don't think it would have
been their choice to have gone in
necessarily so quickly I think it'll
done it because they would have had
their hand forced now whether we've got
some people being rescued they're coming
down the ladder with those they look
like Pompeii coming down at the Pompeii
but I think one or two of them may have
been in civilian dress as well but the
earlier reports we had Rebecca was sixty
to a hundred hostages being held and of
course
allying with the hundred killed that we
now have confirmed by city officials